sie versüßt dir die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du wieder zugeschneit dich mit
backen vom alltag befreit sich mit
weiten von alten frau
ähnlich
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe heute eine schöne silvester idee
für euch und zwar eine fingerfood idee
ein rezept ich mache heute scones und
für das sie später mit einer la creme
wenn er nicht wisst was grund sind mal
schluss da eigentlich
das ist aus kommen eigentlich aus
großbritannien ist es so ein tee gebäck
also mal reicht es in großbritannien
gern zur tea time
und zwar ist es sind so kleine
gepäckstücke
ich werde heute rund machen und es ist
eher herzhaft also saal und salziger
teig aber man kann sie auch mit süßem
belegen also in großbritannien wird auch
zur teatime auch mit marmelade oder
butter gegessen oder auch honig aber ich
mache heute wie gesagt eine herzhafte
creme mit rein und ich finde dass ich
einfach eine super fingerfood idee kam
jetzt entweder zu weihnachten machen so
sylvester oder auch einfach zu anderen
anlässen
denn sie sind auch gut vorzubereiten und
schmecken lecker und wir machen jetzt
zuerst mal den teig und hier habe ich
die zutaten hat 115 20 gramm kalte
butter 450 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel
backpulver einen halben teelöffel salz
eiweiß
hier habe ich 200 milliliter kalte milch
etwas fetter käse und den habe ich
vorher bereits mit einer fein gerieben
als in der küchenmaschine und zum
bestreichen brauche ich dann noch das 1
30 milliliter milch und etwas sesam zum
eintunken ließ sich der detektiv
sherlock holmes
jetzt gebe ich zuerst die das meer in
die schüssel
wir können den teig jetzt auch mit den
händen verkneten aber ein handrührgerät
oder in der küchenmaschine eignet sich
besser denn das soll er ein kalter tag
bleiben wegen der kalten wasser und salz
habe ich rein gegeben dass eike kommt
noch mit rein weiß der zither käse der
stadt richtig schön wird sich eigentlich
nicht aber es eigentlich schon stark im
geschmack finden grünland 19 bisschen
ich finde der pass total super dazu dann
noch die kalte butter
jetzt wird alles gut zusammen geknetet
und die milch gebe ich dann auch zum
schluss mit dazu
der teig ist jetzt fertig und ich rolle
ihnen auf einer silikon matte aus der
wert ist nämlich ausgerollt und
ausgestochen
da hab ich jetzt ein bisschen mehl
darauf gestoppt
ich kriege es nicht mehr mit das wort
gestorben
na ja und jetzt wird der teig so etwa
zwei bis drei zentimeter dick ausgerollt
und da nehme ich jetzt hier meine
ausstecher da habe ich ein ausstieg mit
4 cm durchmesser
aber ihr könnt auch zum beispiel ein
kleines glas nehmen schnapsglas zum
beispiel oder einen kleinen becher könnt
ihr ausstechen und ich setze dann auch
direkt auf ein backblech
fragen
ein bisschen teig immer wieder
zusammengefaltet und wieder ausgestochen
und hat man immer so ein rest und wenn
man den aus holz dann kommt man eben
nicht genau hin mit der menge
deswegen habe ich hier noch ein tipp für
euch nehmt euch einfach den rest dann
tauche ich das so ein bisschen in nähe
und drücke einfach nun reformen mal
ausstechen kann man nicht mehr dann ist
man entweder wegschmeißen oder roh essen
und dann hat man den teig bis zum
letzten aufgebraucht
jetzt versuche ich das eigelb mit der
milch und kann dann die scores damit
bestreichen
jetzt beschlossen noch mit dem see
und so werden sie jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad für ungefähr 25
minuten gebacken und ich nur
zwischenzeit um die creme vorzubereiten
für de la creme habe ich hier schon
meine zutaten und zwar habe ich hier 225
gramm lachs hier habe ich 300 gramm
frischkäse und 100 gramm schmand und
etwas pfeffer und es geht jetzt ganz
schnell muss es einmal mixen
deswegen gebe ich das hier in diesen
mixa rein
dann gebe ich jetzt in frischkäse mit
rein und bei mir war übrigens der lachs
bereits gewürzt also mit bisschen
und wenn ihr das nicht mögt dann könnt
ihr ihn weglassen oder ihr gebt einfach
zusätzlich noch deal mit dazu
jetzt fühle ich dass kurzum denn
ansonsten passt management nicht mehr
mit rein und zwar gebe ich da jetzt noch
100 gramm schmandt mit dazu und noch
etwas besser und früher alles noch mal
miteinander
jetzt will ich die creme in einen
spritzbeutel da habe ich bereits einen
stern schule drauf und stellt sie dann
so lange kühl bis die scones fertig
gebacken sind und bis die dann eben auch
abgekühlt sind
jetzt kann ich die scones befüllen dafür
schneidet in der mitte einmal durch
jetzt sind die stones fertig und ich
finde sie richtig schön vor allem garten
mit der förderung mit dem spritzbeutel
aus angst etwas süßes käme könnte auch
etwas wie es ist ich es jetzt darfst du
probieren
aber nicht ergeben
ich bin von der konsistenz ich habe
jetzt hier auch mal einen ohne füllung
probiert sind die halt also es erinnert
so ein bisschen anmerkt eick aber auch
so ein bisschen an blätterteig durch den
käse als ganze blätter ist ja genau
deswegen blätterteig sowie sein bruder
mit mit lachs in bremen ja und ich habe
zum teil auch ungefüllt gelassen die
kann man zum beispiel auch ganz gut
einfrieren bei bedarf ausbauen
daneben füllen und man kann sich
natürlich mit allen möglichen fühlen als
ihr können sie auch gerne vegetarisch
füllen könnte aber auch zum beispiel in
ton geschrieben reinmachen oder
irgendwie mit trail eine creme natürlich
weil allah oder eine väter kremls
paprika also da könnte wirklich alles
mögliche reinmachen
und das könnte ebenso als grundrezept
und als idee nehmen auf jedenfalls sieht
es wirklich wunderschön aus auf einem
buffet
man kann es aus der hand essen ein
richtig tolles finger foto dürfen
das rezept machen wollt geht einfach auf
meinem blog auf seinem blog de
da steht noch mal alle zutatenangaben
und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal bis dahin tschüss und die ella macht
den mund auf
man drückt halt alles raus beim essen
ich meine du kannst du auch so machen
hat man studiert ja
genial